a story in five
[Applause]
words the story in five words man hates
his secret santa Joe a Christmas loving
employee the worst went all out for
Secret Santa this year but in return was
disar to discover the gift for him was
as a cheap box of chocolates without the
xlax he now says he'll never participate
in secret santa again do you think uh
this is an overreaction a little bit for
a grown man yes to be that mad about
secret santa yeah I I find there's a
foolproof way to do that is what I do
for secret Santa is I wait till the
person leaves and then I just take
something from their desk and wrap it
up and then when they open it and say oh
I I I think this is mine I'll say I knew
you would want something very very good
Tyrus uh this guy uh was mad he's a th%
correct Greg all right why with him in
spirit mm I know his pain oh don't laugh
this is about you too let me talk to my
real
friends secret santa I participated this
year I had Ash one of her little
producers I knew that Ash like horror
movies so I went out and I got Ash a
book about horror movies it was a
phenomenal book Joe you saw it it was
riveting you know what my secret Santa
got me what guess what a bag of candy
and it wasn't the cool kind of candy it
was the little kind of like the
Hershey's that nobody wants no peanuts
in him and you have to open each one up
individually I hate that that's what my
boo that man okay
I'm not going to tell you who he is but
his name was Joe but it's not this Joe
so and then on top of that on top of
that outrage apparently the whole
Gutfeld crew got cheese
boxes from
Greg well I didn't get it and no he did
not know I'm lactose intolerant so
here's the deal I will never ever
participate there will be no secret
Santa I will leak names don't even look
it the gutfield team is jealous of my
awesome gift giving Powers they even do
the Christmas parties on Friday when
they know I fly home so I will I am done
with Christmas done
a r I'm the victim here thank you I had
no idea you cheese boox gille I iate I
um you know I have an idea for secret
Santa Emily everybody sits in a circle
and they each hand $20 to the person on
the left I love that game yeah it's
under 25 bucks totally it works except
for me I'll get
five Tyrus I just want to tell you that
your book was amazing and that secret
Santa is totally about the giver and the
person who gave you the chocolate just
didn't know what to do I'm sure with
every person I ever dated they're still
mad at
me my secret Santa gift by the way which
I think it also tells you like what
people think about you mine had to do
with coffee it warms my coffee because
I'm always running around and then a
little thing that sits on my desk about
angels because of my faith I feel seen
and loved and I feel like for your
advice what would be great is Whoever
has you next year should just give you
your mirr again that got stolen by the
weekend team yes the evil Fox and friend
weekend
team cat uh this guy seems very needy I
hate the guy yeah sorry t yeah I hate
the guy I can I know exactly who this
guy is he went above and beyond so that
he could be like I went above and beyond
for you like nobody's asking you to do
that it's secret Santa at work it's not
that big of a deal he needs to calm down
he's somebody who gives performatively
so that he can then say I was wrong yeah
don't you have a girlfriend a family or
a dog and his chocolates weren't
individually wrapped either I just like
to point that out now now I feel bad
that you gave me two of those cheese
[Laughter]
boxes one of you ain't getting out of
here
tonight hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else